[Applause]
in Sydney they came in there thousands a
sea of people with one goal to save the
planet this is the start of a day of
global climate strikes inspired by teen
activist Greta tunberg a united call for
action to show that we stand together
United in our commitment to climate
justice
the majority change as the world rallies
in Indonesia thousands of fires are
worsening the current climate crisis
smoke now chokes parts of Malaysia
a neighboring Singapore with residents
forced to breathe toxic air in Kuala
lumper volunteers hand out face masks in
the hope of offering some protection
they've given away twenty thousand in
just four days it makes me very
depressed because you look out of the
window in the señorita you normally used
to you don't see them anymore buildings
hills they've just disappeared under the
haze and it makes you feel worried
because you don't know how is it
affecting your health this is the air
you're reading in from here you can see
just how limited the visibility is and
the fires raging in parts of Southeast
Asia aren't just affecting people's
health
locally they're also pumping masses of
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere
that contributes to climate change and
impacts everyone in the world in the UK
these teenagers fear the time to act is
running out they're preparing to rally
later today they say everyone has a duty
to step up we're getting off and we're
doing something and if people don't join
us and politicians don't hear us if
governments don't listen to us then
they'll be on the wrong side of history
these strikes could be the biggest
environmental protest the world has ever
seen millions of people fighting for all
our futures
Siobhan Robbins Sky News